okay this was submitted by RJ Murray 666
on Twitter
so the Chinese baby boys gonna give you
a better look yeah Chinese scientists
have found a way that's currently in the
works for them to cure cauliflower ears
non-surgically Wow and so it says that
the technique involves a digital
micromirror device and bio-ink which is
made up of cartilage cells and different
chemicals it's injected to the back of
the ear after 20 seconds the the year
began take form may provide a surgery
free option for humans with this
condition who often undergo surgical
implantation that the risk of injury
more brothers 3d printing technique may
open a new avenues for mounting places
Wow
3d printing I don't know I would do it I
don't know it's kind of a badge of honor
but people already know you haven't or
you had up what's like Brian Guinness
let's done it's like it's really good
yeah can you wear ear pods no see that
might be right when I post play show my
bike grooms like dude I thought you had
money dude you still win wires I'm like
yeah I like the wires do like Haiti err
putts they fall out I lose them Nicholas
you where you use wires
hey bro damn you and I'm you I and now
it's Roman times richer than you and I
still know why you're four times richer
just as my show got cancelled there it
is it's actually us I'm not happy about
the lot of stuff and that's that hurt my
feelings rich like I have nothing with
my feelings and that made me do the
pocket surpress for so long ah it's okay
Brian Elon Musk no I'm sorry um I'm
sorry were you saying about my money oh
do tell my earpods
I can't wear them today Luke there
my pros have the plastic yeah they have
the plastic that wraps around what is it
man
doesn't work dude he's mom on the trails
like this they fall out yeah I can't
afford a bike that's cool I don't know
if I do it like I said I had the
opportunity to go on the BOTS show and
they were gonna fix it listen I had two
surgeries on this air because got so big
last fighting they said could come off
in a fight besides surgery
come on my fart yet happened to Leslie
Smith I've had by fart this and it's my
worst one I think the guy was a fan it
might have been a dentist he was a big
fan he's like I can figure it out I can
be done before he's like no but it's
pretty it's pretty up front I can do it
and then I remember taking off this is
awful so he slid open all the blood and
he's a dentist I'm pretty sure but he
slid it open with a knife that felt good
my ear was out to here split open it all
lose doubt he packed it with like stuff
stitch it up I went about my business
for about three or four weeks on stitch
it took the stitching out well clearly
it doesn't work that way because the
body goes oh there's a there's a void we
got to fill it with fluid which is what
happens sure and then it hardens and now
am i you're super funny I suppose have a
drain right with a syringe that does it
that doesn't work
let me I've drained I dreamed I used to
drain both I have to practice all day in
my elbow all day I wasn't out of the
city on my elbow when I fought Kris
touches her [ __ ] I got that eyebrows I
was in the back with Greg Jackson had
this huge titty on I was trying to drain
it before I go what am I gonna do I mean
how am I gonna throw elbows and Greg
Jesse knows what how many throw boys yes
have you ever stolen elbow in a fight
you know he goes who gives a [ __ ] yeah
you're probably right you'll take that
needle on your elbow all right I got I
got an exact same don't know don't do
that yes I did and I thought I was done
but it didn't but I didn't do anything
might you know my Kutner missile blown
you guys got orange sauce I got my coach
goes ah sugar he goes ah sugar that
thing blew up like a [ __ ] basketballs
I don't know I fought through it though
then did your mom go sweetie
I saw a broken
- hmm again high school I don't know I
can't remember high school college
that's got way easier left you're
heavier than your right does it feel
that way no it does let me ask the
question course not that's a little
definitely weird yeah yeah come on it
solidifies it some weight to it
Oh nothing's better than a dad joke when
throwing does does it affect your hair
now huh dad joke okay right now yeah
yeah yeah yeah watch your tongue oh good
what's gonna happen what are you gonna
do use some of that boxing you've been
doing
[Laughter]